the accusations against Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh have echoes from
another famous Senate Judiciary
Committee hearing in 1991 professor
Anita Hill accused Supreme Court nominee
Clarence Thomas of sexual harassment
nearly 27 years later professor
Christine Blasi Ford's allegations
against Judge Cavanaugh are unfolding in
a familiar way Jan Crawford looks at the
striking parallels and differences Jan
good morning well go so there are a lot
of similarities I mean you've got two
conservative nominees they both
adamantly denied us two female
professors come forward with the
allegations but there are a lot of key
differences and also it's a different
time I felt that I had to tell the truth
it was 1991 professor Anita Hill accused
Supreme Court nominee Clarence Thomas of
sexual harassment while she worked for
him in the 1980s he spoke about acts
that he had seen in pornographic films
involving such matters as women having
sex with animals and films showing group
sex or rape scenes I deny each and every
single allegation against me today as
evening Clarence Thomas blamed the
Senate for conducting what he saw as a
racist smear campaign as a black
American as far as I'm concerned it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks so
when you think about Anita Hill what do
you think happened there I mean she upon
us with you what I care about is that
the responsible people didn't put an end
to this nonsense professor do you swear
to tell the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God all-male
all-white members of the Senate
Judiciary Committee attach hills
credibility that angered Georgetown Law
Professor Emma Coleman Jordan she
advised Hill at the time it sees
parallels with today's Ford Kavanagh
hearing this one is even more dramatic
because the position that Judge
Cavanaugh has been nominated for is the
swing seat where the stakes are high
because of women's autonomy in the
what to do with their bodies another
important difference the makeup of the
Senate Judiciary Committee well
fortunately we have women who are on
this committee they're Democrats but
they are women and the culture has
changed
Ford's allegations of sexual misconduct
come in the wake of the raging meetyou
movement once the allegation of sexual
impropriety is made then it tends to
stick for former Missouri senator john
danforth watching the Cavanaugh
accusations unfold is like watching a
remake of an old movie what I advised
Clarence Thomas at the time was if it's
in your heart say it and that's what I
would say to Judge Cavanaugh as well now
of course you know Thomas then Cavanaugh
now they have not only deny the
allegations but say it's just like come
out of nowhere they've never been
accused of anything like this you know
Thomas was ultimately confirmed to the
Supreme Court of course but you know
what's interesting if you look back at
polls at the time a majority the
American people did not believe in Nita
Hill after they testified only 27
percent after her testimony thought she
was telling the truth it's so eerily
similar these two cases
thank you very much Jan